in the wake of Saturday's terrorist
attack in London the city's mayor Sadiq
Khan spoke on TV and he was doing what
he thought of to keep Londoners calm he
made the statements you'd expect any
mayor to make after their city is
attacked by terrorists Sunday morning
the morning after the terrorist attack
in London our President Donald Trump
posted a series of tweets criticizing
the Mayor of London London Sadiq Khan
for his statements saying he's not
reacting harshly enough saying quote we
must get down to the business of
security for our people if we don't get
smart it will only get worse so after a
tweet like that and attacking the Mayor
of London for not getting serious enough
or working hard enough what did Donald
Trump do that day in the efforts of
getting down to business he traveled to
Trump International Golf Club in
Virginia and played his 23rd game of
golf in 19 weeks of presidency this was
his second day in a row playing golf
Trump had also played golf the day
before in the middle of everything
that's going on in London with the
terrorist attacks there's protests going
on all over our country demanding an
investigation that's an actually
independent into the Trump Russia
connections his 23rd game of golf in 19
weeks as president Trump still averaging
more than a game of golf per week most
people who are not president of the
United States don't have this much time
to play golf
never mind the President of the United
States I used to try to play golf what I
would consider frequently five years ago
or so I had like a group of friends that
we would try to play golf I wasn't even
that busy and I still could play maybe
once every couple of weeks and I had a
very little going on at the time it
would be really hard to average more
than once a week that's what he's doing
now but you know Republicans like Peter
King were super upset when Obama wore a
tan suit after the beheading of James
Foley right so I'm sure they're going to
livid about this oh yeah they're all up
in arms saying that this is the end for
Donald Trump not only was it odd for
Trump to criticize another government
leader for not getting down to business
while he was on his second straight day
of a golf vacation Trump plays way more
golf than oboe
ever did but recall that Obama's golfing
was a really big issue for Trump during
the Obama presidency he tweeted a bunch
of times for example quote President
Obama played golf yesterday then going
on to say I play golf to relax my
company is in great shape Barack Obama
plays golf to escape work while America
goes down the drain and lastly can you
believe that with all of the problems
and difficulties facing the u.s.
President Obama spent the day playing
golf
worse than Carter Trump has played 23
games of golf at this point in his
presidency President Obama had played
four and I've already told you in the
past how Trump is accused of cheating at
golf this apparently is a really big
thing Alice Cooper told Q magazine I
wish I could tell you that it would be a
shocker I played with Donald Trump one
time that's all I'm going to say
alluding to cheating when playing golf
by Donald Trump and Rick Reilly in who's
your caddy writing quote Golf is like
bicycle shorts it can reveal a lot about
a guy when it comes to cheating he's an
11 on the scale of 1 to 10 so bottom
line it for me Pat how much worse is the
fact that Trump cheats at golf given
that he's playing more than a game of
golf a week like do you not care about
the cheating because the amount he's
playing is bad enough
or is it pathetic that he's also
cheating at golf I mean the cheating's
not really so much of a big deal I think
when you're president too you're given a
certain amount of Mulligan's because
people that you're playing against
aren't going to go too hard on you maybe
I'm not understanding the etiquette of
presidential golfing or whatever the
case may be
in any case Trump really getting serious
and down to business now because there's
a lot of work to be done
apparently golfing two days in a row
we'll take a break discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash reddit
today's program is made possible in part
by Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also string
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s